[Music]
you're hearing a lot these days that
that everyone's fragile everyone's a
snowflake and and who who someone's
pointing the finger at depends a great
deal in their their political ideology
and what the research is showing is that
everyone everyone wants the sensor
someone everyone thinks somebody else is
wrong they just disagree on who should
be silenced and who is who is incorrect
one of the things I've been excited to
see is is the work of some of the folks
like Jonathan Hyde at NYU who make the
case that human beings are anti fragile
in the sense that we get better we get
stronger we get more resilient and more
capable dealing with the world when we
when we encounter difficulties and and
overcome them I think that has huge
relevance to the free expression
conversation because fundamentally
dealing with free expression is
difficult supporting the idea of free
expression means supporting the idea or
the existence of even offensive speech
that's not a small thing we're cognizant
of the fact that we're talking about
free expression in an era where
self-identified white nationalists and
Nazis are marching down the streets in
Charlottesville and people are dying
trying to peacefully counter protest
those ideas I'm thinking of a story that
I think is powerful and somewhat
representative of the good things that
come as people feel comfortable to
express even even nasty views I was
listening to NPR and heard the story of
Darrell Davis he's a jazz and blues
musician who began he's an
african-american gentleman he began
collecting KKK memorabilia as basically
a reminder of how far the civil rights
movement has come but how far we still
have to go as a society in terms of
eliminating bigotry and Prejudice and in
the course of of collecting this
memorabilia he came into contact with a
lot of current or former members of the
KKK or family members of those people
who had sympathies to those abhorrent
views and
he was just sitting down and talking to
these people he was having drinks with
him at a bar he was conversing with them
and and often he would hear these people
say that they've never met a black
person they've never actually had a
conversation so much of what they'd been
taught had never been challenged through
dialogue of that sort and it's it's you
hear this on college campuses a lot it
is entirely unfair that a that a Darryl
Davis has to bear the weight of those
bigoted views and be the person who
engages in the difficult exercise of
dialogue but over the course of his life
of doing this he's converted you know
more than 200 KKK members to to turn in
their robes to disavow their beliefs and
ultimately to recognize that they were
wrong hating somebody on the basis of
skin color so how can we promote a
culture of openness in society that
makes us as individuals receptive to
engaging with even even the most
deplorable views with the the goal of
changing them at the end of the day I
mean John Stuart Mill nerd I think
nothing but good things happen when you
engage with ideas with which you
disagree you either learn how to better
defend your position maybe you move
closer to truth maybe you persuade the
other of a given view but either way
you've all learned something and been
made better by that encounter so there's
there's a role for protest there's a
role for civil disobedience there's a
role for robust disagreement it just
means that your disagreement has to stop
short of violating the rights of others
it stops short of you know your fist at
my nose or you know you stepping onto my
property or causing harm so I don't
think civility is necessarily the be-all
end-all goal in and of itself what's
more important is I think fostering an
inherent respect and dignity for every
human being and recognizing that even if
you disagree with an individual they are
a human with inherent Worth and value
who shouldn't be
armed
[Music]